Hey everyone.  We have two videos that are going to be looking at indirect price discrimination.
And each video has its own purpose.
The first one here is to look at how we do product versions.
That is, we're going to be indirectly price discriminating based on the versions of products that people want to buy.
And then we'll have a look at the pricing versions in our second video.
But let's go ahead and jump into this first one and let's first ask, what is indirect price discrimination?
Well, quite simply, it occurs when a seller cannot directly identify high and low value customers or consumers.
So imagine you have all these people here who want to purchase this streaming service.
Okay, that's great.
They're all going to the streaming service.
But we cannot look at that group of people and determine do they want ads or do they not want ads?
Are they willing to pay more for no ads or are they satisfied with ads and paying for a lesser price?
So this creates an issue for the firm and one in which we need to create versions of the product and then let this thing called self selection take place.
Now that's the important part of indirect price discrimination.
You allow these people to self select or self sort into the product that they want.
Now what we're going to be doing here is designing these pricing structures.
They're going to lead consumers to go to where they're willing to pay for for a particular version of the product that they want.
So if they don't want ads, then they're going to be willing to pay a little bit more to not have those ads in that streaming service.
Imagine this person here trying to choose between a basic pro and premium version of a mobile app.
So what we need to do as the firm is design these versions so that we allow the person to self select based on their willingness to pay into that particular product.
And that allows us to extract more of the consumer surplus and turn into profit for the firm.
Now there are a few ways to do this.
We're going to look at a bunch of different ways, but let's go ahead and get a few of these out of the way.
The first is volume discounts.
Here we charge less as more as bought.
Common examples, paper towels, bottled water, freight shipping, data storage.
As you purchase more of these items more together, what you see is that you get a per unit discount as your purchases increase, as the volume of your purchases increase, two part tariffs.
You charge an access fee and then you charge a per use fee.
Gym memberships are a prime example of this.
Here you charge a monthly membership to go to the gym.
And then if you want to take classes, then you charge.
You pay a little bit extra for those classes.
And there are some other ones there as well.
And then versioning offer multiple products or combinations.
Here we have the basic pro and premium versions of this app which allows different functionality.
With the premium version you get the full functionality of the product, but with the basic version you have limited functionality.
Microsoft Office is a good example.
Netflix, the iPhone and Uber.
You can get the different types of Uber based off of what you want.
Do you want the uberX?
Are you okay with just the basic ride share?
All right, so we allow people to self select into whatever version they want based off of their willingness to pay for those items.
Now some other ways that we can look at our indirect price discrimination.
This damage good strategy.  All right.
Damage good strategy.
Here we're making versions of our premium product worse.
Not necessarily worse in the sense that it's such a lower grade quality, but we take some things away from it.
That protects the high end version.
We take some things away from the protects the high end version.
Think about your first class seats versus your economy seats.
You get more room.
It's all the same product.
You're all going one place, right, but you get more room.
You get a bit better service, but you also pay a premium price for that.
Here again we're letting customers self select based off of what their willingness to pay is.
If someone is willing to pay $1,000 for a first class ticket versus let's say four or five hundred dollars for the economy ticket, then they are self selecting.
They're revealing their own preferences to the airline and that allows that airline to indirectly price discriminate.
Let's consider Spotify with this.
With the free Spotify it's $0, but it includes ads.
I think you get six skips per hour.
And, and you can't download music for any offline listening.
But if you pay 11.99amonth, then you don't have any ads.
You've got unlimited skips and you can download music for offline listening.
So the premium version here versus the basic version, we have made the basic version worse.
We're trying to protect that high end version because you know, you have the ads and you have the limited skips and the no downloads for offline listening.
So which do you prefer?
What is Spotify attempting to capture?
Trying to capture more consumer surplus based on the market because we don't know our consumer market.
So we have to let the consumers reveal themselves.
Next is the metering Strategy here we're going to charge based on usage.
The more you use, the more we charge.
But it might get at a per unit discount as we charge a little bit more.
As you use a little bit more, high usage consumers are definitely going to pay more.
Here's an example of a metering strategy.
This is actually going to be a water utility and you can see how it is charged per volume or per CCF.
So between 1 CCF to 15 CCFs we only charge $2.2.27.
Anything over the 15 CCF we charge $2.52.
So the more you use then the more we charge.
But it allows consumers who are high usage consumers to get what they pay for.
So here you can look at three different breakdowns.
The first is only using 4ccf per month and they're charged a total of 1971.
But as we use more, we go to our next one, it's 5ccf, we get charged 2198 per month.
Okay, but if you look at someone who uses a lot of water, in this case, they went through the first 15 CCF and then they got to the next one.
So 16 total and their total bill was $47.20.
Now why does metering strategy work?
Because it aligns price with usage.
We're going to charge you more based off of your volume of usage.
And again it allows people to self select into what they want.
High usage consumers will use more, low usage consumers will use less.
Which is great for the next point.
Allows for onboarding of light users.
So as someone who is going into a metering product, if you are not a high volume user, you can still access the product but at a lower usage with what you want to use it for.
So maybe over time you develop into a high usage consumer, but initially it allows for that firm to bring in the low usage consumer to get them onboarded to the product.
And then it captures more surplus from the high value users.
And again that's what firms are trying to do.
They're trying to capture that consumer surplus and turn it into producer surplus.
Some other examples here that we have Uber and Lyft.  Fair.
Based on the usage that you're doing, are you using more, are you going further distances or those kind of things.
Car rentals, you could be charged per mile.
Then mobile data plans, gigabytes of data.
How much gigs gigabytes of data do you want?
And then natural gas charged per the British thermal units.
I believe that's what BTU stands for.
So the more that you use the more that is charged.
So it's just like our water utility bills that we see here.
Now, why do these strategies all work?
Few reasons.  First, allows consumers again to self select based on their willingness to pay.
We don't know because this is indirect price discrimination.
We don't know our segment in market, we don't know which consumers are low value, which ones are high value.
So we allow them to self select into what they want.
Now, direct price discrimination, on the other hand, that requires the firm to identify consumer types.
Well, if we just stay with these strategies, the versioning in these strategies, we don't have to worry about identifying those consumer types.
So it takes away part of the problem that we would have.
So this allows us to create that menu of options and again, allowing those consumers to reveal their own preferences and maximize their own utility.
As they're maximizing their utility, we're actually getting more of their consumer surplus because we can get the low value consumers to their segment of the market, we can get the high value consumers to their segment of the market and then that allows us to capture more total value inside the firm.
So with our damage good strategy, our metering strategy with the, with different other strategies inside of indirect price discrimination, we can see how offering different versions of the products that we want to sell allow us to capture more of the total value inside of the market.
And that is it for this one.  Hope you've enjoyed it.